.
WELL, IT TURNS OUT A LOT OF
PARENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
FED UP WITH THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM WHICH WE SHOULD CALL THE
GOVERNMENT SCHOOL SYSTEM.
SO MUCH SO THAT THEY'RE PULLING
THEIR KIDS OUT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BY THE TRUCK LOADS.
AND INSTEAD TURNING TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS, CHRISTIAN SCHOOLS,
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND HOME
SCHOOLING.
ACCORDING TO AN ANALYSIS ON THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE FOR PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS, DURING THE
2020, 2021 SCHOOL YEAR, CHARTER
SCHOOL ENROLLMENT GREW 7%.
THE LARGEST IN HALF A DECADE
SAME FOR PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
BY COMPARISON DISTRICT SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT DROPPED PRECIPITOUSLY
IN EVERY STATE.
TO BE EXACT.
1.4 MILLION STUDENTS LEFT THEIR
GOVERNMENT-RUN SCHOOL DISTRICT.
1.4 MILLION AMERICAN KIDS WITH A
NEW LEASE ON LEARNING.
NOW, YOU CAN TRY TO BLAME THIS
ON COVID-19 AND SHUTDOWNS AND
JAMMING MASKS ON 5-YEAR-OLDS,
ALL YOU WANT.
BUT THE TRUTH IS, PARENTS ARE
ALSO FED UP WITH THE MARXIST
CURRICULUM BEING TAUGHT IN
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS, WE ARE DONE.
WE DON'T WANT OUR KIDS TO BE
INDOCTRINATED WITH GENDER
NEUTRALITIES NONSENSE, THE
RELIGION OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
RACIST CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
THE LEFT HAS COMPLETELY CAPTURED
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I CAN'T SAY THAT MORE
EMPHATICALLY.
I WAS A PUBLIC SCHOOL KID.
I'M SURE MANY OF YOU WERE, TOO.
BUT THE SCHOOLS OF YESTERYEAR
ARE LONG GONE.
KIDS LEARNING FROM HOME DURING
COVID-19 EXPOSED THEIR PARENTS
TO POISONOUS CURRICULUM LIKE SAY
THE 1619 PROJECT.
I CALL WHAT HAPPENED THE COVID
1619 EFFECT.
PARENTS HAVE FOUND A REAL VIRUS
AND IT'S IN THE TEXTBOOKS.
IT'S THE WOKE VERSUS THE NEWLY
AWAKE.
AND THE ONLY HOPE FOR OUR
COUNTRY IS FOR THIS TREND TO
CONTINUE.
JOINING ME NOW FORMER UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR AND AUTHOR OF BLACK
EYE FOR AMERICA HOW CRITICAL
RACE THEORY IS BURNING DOWN THE
HOUSE CAROL SWAIN AND NORTH
CAROLINA LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
MARK ROBINSON.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
CARROLL, LET ME START WITH YOU,
IS IT A GOOD THING THAT A
MILLION AND A HALF AMERICAN KIDS
ARE SAYING I'M OUT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL?
>> IT'S A WONDERFUL THING.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF US
HAVE CALLED FOR FOR A LONG TIME,
PETE.
AND SO I'M PROUD OF AMERICAN
PARENTS WHO ARE PULLING THEIR
CHILDREN OUT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
BUT THE REST OF US, WHETHER WE
HAVE CHILDREN OR NOT IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, WE NEED TO STAND
UP FIGHT FOR THE CHILDREN THOUGH
ARE TRAPPED AND LEFT BEHIND.
THEY HAVE RIGHTS TO AND RIGHT
NOW THEY ARE BEING ABUSED BY THE
CURRICULUM.
>> WELL SAID.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, YOU WERE
PART OF A REPORT IN NORTH
CAROLINA CALLED THE
INDOCTRINATION IN NORTH CAROLINA
PUBLIC EDUCATION REPORT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU BELIEVE AT THIS
DAY AND AGE IS HAPPENING AT OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS?
>> ABSOLUTELY I DO.
I SAW IT FIRSTHAND WITH MY
CHILDREN WHEN THEY WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
I SAW IT AT THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL
MYSELF WHEN I WAS AN ADULT
CHILDREN IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
AND THE ENTIRE TIME THAT I HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN CAMPAIGNING AND
NOW AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
FOLKS HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT TO
ME ALL ACROSS THE STATE WITH
THESE CONCERNS.
THIS IS NOT AS SOME POLITICIANS
HAVE CLAIMED A CONSPIRACY DRIVEN
ISSUE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO TACKLE.
AND OUR OFFICE IS DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO DO
JUST THAT.
>> Pete: CAROL, WHAT ARE PARENTS
MISSING THAT SAY, WELL, MY
PUBLIC SCHOOL IS OKAY.
MAYBE THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT STUFF.
WHEN YOU SEND YOUR KIDS TO A
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN THAT SENSE,
WHAT ARE THEY MISSING OUT OF
THAT THEY OTHERWISE SHOULD BE
GETTING?
>> WELL, THEY ARE MISSING THE
FACT THAT THE TEACHERS, THE
EDUCATED IN CRITICAL RACE THEORY
AND SO THEY COME OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENTS OF EDUCATION AT THE
UNIVERSITIES STEEPED IN IT.
IT IS THE CLASSROOMS AND PARENTS
ARE JUST NOW, EXCUSE ME,
LEARNING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
AND IT TAKES AWAY FROM ACADEMIC
LEARNING WHEN ADVANCED PLACEMENT
COURSES ARE REMOVED FROM
SCHOOLS.
WHEN STANDARDS ARE LOWERED FOR
MINORITY STUDENTS.
WHEN MESSAGES ARE SENT ABOUT
WHITE PRIVILEGE AND MINORITIES
BEING VICTIMS AND RACISM BEING
PERMANENT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
DAMAGING AND IT CREATES A
HOSTILE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR
OUR STUDENTS, HOSTILE TEACHING
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE TEACHERS,
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR AMERICA.
WE NEED TO KEEP PUSHING BACK.
>> Pete: LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
HAVE YOU BEEN CALLED RACIST OR
ON THE WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY FOR
DARING TO DARE THAT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY OR DIVERSITY EQUITY,
INCLUSION MAYBE ISN'T A GOOD
THING IN OUR PUBLIC CLASSROOMS.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAD A MAJOR NEWS OUTLET THAT
FEATURED THE CARTOON FEATURING
ME AND ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
STATE SCHOOL BOARD A NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMAN AS CLUE DELUXE
CLANSMEN BECAUSE WE SIMPLY
WANTED TO TEACH WHAT'S FLIGHT
HISTORY AND WHAT'S RIGHT IN THE
CLASSROOM.
WE HAVE BEEN DEMONIZED BY MANY
OF THOSE ON THE LEFT.
WE CHOOSE NOT TO LISTEN TO THOSE
VOICES.
WE LISTENED TO THOSE PARENTS AND
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS WHO ARE
REACHING OUT TO US EVERY DAY.
AND DEMANDING THAT SOMETHING BE
DONE ABOUT THIS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
>> Pete: I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOU
BOTH.
THOSE TEACHERS UNIONS HAVE A
STRANGLEHOLD ON PLACES STATES
CAN FIGHT BACK BUT BEST OPTION
IF YOU CAN IF YOU HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR OPTIONS I'M OUT OF
HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO PLAY BY THE
GOVERNMENT'S RULES BECAUSE MY
LIFE, MY KID'S LIFE IS AT STAKE.